it was striking the degree to which not
just the regular military but also the
National Guard forces and the National
Guard are meant to be the internal
security force that keeps control of the
streets when push came to shove they
preferred to sit it out they certainly
didn't feel the kind of loyalty to Putin
that meant that they interposed
themselves to the fast-moving Wagner
columns it doesn't mean to say that the
entire military wouldn't have fought if
it was a foreign Invasion or that in
fact they're all ready to support any
kind of challenge at Putin but it does
mean that he can no longer count on
their support and I think this will be
crucial because what we're seeing is a
hollowing out of the state it still
looks impressive but in fact it's much
less substantial than it was before and
then well what's going to be the next
Black Swan event this was unexpected and
this has been dealt with but at a cost
leaving the regime even weaker for
whatever the next Crisis and emerges and
one thing we can say in politics is
there will always be a next Crisis